so I hired as marketing agency and they  come in and they say we should do this a  marketing agency you pay them the money  they present you the product the video  the commercial whatever it may be and  then you say no and then from there you  give them access if they're using your  Twitter account you give them access if  they're using your Instagram Instagram  account you give them access to all your  social a marketing company doesn't come  and post anything on your Instagram  account without your permission  Balenciaga so unless if this marketing  company came in with a gun put to your  head at the board meeting saying give us  all your passwords let us post this with  the following and let you get some  backlash no this 25 million dollar  lawsuit is not the marketings company  you agreed for this thing to be posted  you get 100 of the responsibility stop  thinking people are dumb